Les économistes ont exploré le comportement des gens
depuis des centaines d'années :
comment nous prenons des décisions,
comment nous agissons individuellement et en groupe,
comment nous échangeons des valeurs.
Ils ont étudié les institutions qui facilitent notre commerce,
comme les systèmes légaux,
les entreprises,
les marchés.
Mais il y a une nouvelle institution technologique
qui va fondamentalement changer notre façon d'échanger la valeur
et c'est la blockchain.
C'est une affirmation audacieuse,
mais si vous ne deviez retenir qu'une chose de cette présentation,
je veux que vous vous souveniez
que, si la technologie de la blockchain est récente,
c'est aussi une continuation d'une histoire très humaine
que voici.
En tant qu'humains, nous trouvons le moyen
de diminuer les doutes que nous avons envers les autres
afin de pouvoir échanger la valeur.
L'une des premières personnes à avoir vraiment exploré l'idée
des institutions comme outil économique
pour diminuer nos doutes envers les autres
et pouvoir faire du commerce
était le prix Nobel de l'économie, Douglass North.
Il est décédé fin 2015
mais North était un précurseur de la « nouvelle économie institutionnelle ».
Et ce qu'il entendait par institutions était en fait des règles formelles,
comme une constitution,
et des contraintes informelles, comme la corruption.
Ces institutions sont la graisse
permettant aux roues de l'économie de tourner
et nous pouvons le voir à travers le cours de l'histoire humaine.
Si nous en revenons aux économies où nous étions chasseurs-cueilleurs,
nous faisions du commerce dans la structure de notre village.
Il y avait des contraintes informelles
mais nous imposions tout notre commerce par la violence
ou des répercussions sociales.
Alors que nos sociétés se sont complexifiées
et que nos routes de commerce se sont étendues,
nous avons bâti des institutions plus formelles,
des institutions telles que les banques pour la monnaie,
les gouvernements, les entreprises.
Ces institutions nous ont aidés à gérer le commerce
alors que l'incertitude et la complexité augmentaient
et que notre contrôle personnel était fortement diminué.
Finalement, avec internet, nous avons mis ces institutions en ligne.
Nous avons construit des places de marché
comme Amazon, eBay, Alibaba,
des institutions plus rapides servant d'intermédiaires
pour facilité l'activité économique humaine.
Comme le voyait Douglass North,
les institutions sont un outil pour diminuer l'incertitude
afin que nous nous connections et échangions des valeurs en société.
Je crois que nous entrons aujourd'hui
dans une évolution nouvelle et radicale
sur notre façon d'interagir et de faire du commerce
car, pour la première fois, nous pouvons diminuer l'incertitude
non seulement avec des institutions politiques et économiques
comme nos banques, nos entreprises, nos gouvernements,
mais cela est faisable uniquement avec la technologie.
Qu'est-ce que la blockchain ?
La technologie de la blockchain est une base de données décentralisée
qui conserve un registre des actifs et des transactions
à travers un réseau pair-à-pair.
Globalement, c'est un registre public
de qui détient quoi et qui effectue quelle transaction.
Les transactions sont sécurisées grâce à un chiffrement
et, avec le temps, l'historique de transactions
est verrouillé sous forme de blocs de données
qui sont liés ensemble et sécurisés par cryptographie.
Cela créé un registre inaltérable et infalsifiable
de toutes les transactions dans le réseau.
Ce registre est répliqué sur tous les ordinateurs du réseau.
Ce n'est pas une application.
Ce n'est pas une entreprise.
Je pense que la description est plus proche d'une chose telle Wikipédia.
Nous pouvons tout voir sur Wikipédia.
C'est une vue composite qui est constamment changée et mise à jour.
Sur Wikipédia, nous pouvons pister ces changements au fil du temps
et créer nos propres wikis
car ce sont essentiellement de simples infrastructures de données.
Wikipédia est une plateforme ouverte qui stocke des mots et des images
et les changements de données faits au fil du temps.
Pour la blockchain,
vous pouvez la voir comme une infrastructure ouverte
qui stocke tous genres d'actifs.
Elle stocke l'historique de garde,
de propriété et de lieu
pour des actifs tels que la monnaie numérique Bitcoin,
d'autres actifs numériques
comme le titre de propriété intellectuelle.
Cela pourrait être un certificat, un contrat,
des objets réels,
même des informations à caractère personnel.
Il y a d'autres détails techniques sur la blockchain,
mais elle fonctionne ainsi, globalement.
C'est ce registre public qui enregistre les transactions dans un réseau
et est répliqué afin d'être sécurisé et difficile à falsifier.
Ce qui m'amène à dire
que la blockchain diminue l'incertitude
et promet ainsi de transformer nos systèmes économiques
de façon radicale.
L'incertitude est un terme important
en économie
et j'aimerais parler de trois formes
auxquelles nous faisons face dans toutes nos transactions quotidiennes
où la blockchain peut jouer un rôle.
Il y a des incertitudes concernant la personne avec qui nous traitons,
l'absence de visibilité lors de la transaction
et l'absence de recours si quelque chose tourne mal.
Prenons le premier exemple : ne pas savoir avec qui nous traitons.
Disons que je veux acheter un téléphone d'occasion sur eBay.
La première chose que je vais faire est de vérifier à qui j'achète.
Est-ce un utilisateur avancé ?
A-t-il de bons commentaires et notes ou aucun profil ?
Les commentaires, notes, vérifications :
ce sont des attestations de notre identité
que nous rassemblons
et utilisons pour diminuer l'incertitude sur la personne avec qui nous traitons.
Mais le problème est que tout cela est très fragmenté.
Pensez à combien de profils vous avez.
La blockchain nous permet de créer une plateforme ouverte, mondiale
sur laquelle stocker toute attestation concernant un individu
quelle qu'en soit la source.
Cela nous permet de créer une identité portable contrôlée par l'utilisateur.
Plus qu'un profil,
cela signifie que vous pouvez choisir de révéler
les différents attributs vous concernant
qui aideront à faciliter l'échange ou l'interaction.
Par exemple que vous avez une pièce d'identité gouvernementale
ou que vous avez plus de 21 ans,
en révélant la preuve cryptographique
que ces détails existent et sont conformes.
Avoir ce type d'identité portable
dans le monde physique et le monde numérique
signifie que nous pouvons faire tout type de commerce humain
de façon totalement nouvelle.
Voilà comment cela pourrait diminuer l'incertitude
vis-à-vis de la personne en face.
La seconde incertitude à laquelle nous faisons face
est de ne pas avoir de transparence dans nos interactions.
Disons que vous m'envoyez ce téléphone par colis.
Je veux une certaine transparence.
Je veux savoir que ce que j'ai acheté est ce qui va arriver dans le colis
et qu'il y a une trace de comment il m'est arrivé.
Ce n'est pas vrai uniquement pour l'électronique
mais pour nombre de biens et de données
comme les médicaments, les biens de luxe,
tout type de données ou produit qui ne doit pas être trafiqué.
Le problème dans beaucoup d'entreprises,
en particulier celles qui produisent quelque chose de complexe,
est qu'elles gèrent tous ces vendeurs différents
à travers une chaîne logistique horizontale.
Toutes ces personnes qui vont créer le produit
n'ont pas la même base de données.
Elles n'utilisent pas la même infratructure
et il est donc difficile de voir de façon transparente
l'évolution d'un produit au fil du temps.
Avec la blockchain, nous pouvons créer
une réalité partagée par des entités ne se faisant pas confiance.
Ce que je veux dire,
c'est que tous ces nœuds du réseau n'ont pas besoin de se connaître
ou de se faire confiance
car ils sont tous en capacité
de surveiller et valider la chaîne eux-mêmes.
Repensez à Wikipédia.
C'est une base de données partagée
et, même s'il y a de multiples lecteurs
et de multiples auteurs en même temps,
il n'y a qu'une seule vérité.
Nous pouvons créer cela avec la blockchain.
Nous pouvons créer une base de données décentralisée,
aussi efficace qu'un monopole, sans avoir à créer d'autorité centrale.
Tous ces vendeurs, toutes sortes d'entreprises
peuvent interagir avec la même base de données sans se faire confiance.
Pour les consommateurs, cela signifie plus de transparence.
Lorsqu'un objet réel voyage,
nous pouvons voir son certificat numérique se déplacer dans la chaîne,
augmentant sa valeur au passage.
C'est un nouveau monde en terme de visibilité.
Nous avons parlé de comment la blockchain
peut diminuer nos incertitudes sur l'identité
et comment elle change le sens du terme « transparence »
dans les échanges longue distance, complexes comme dans la chaîne logistique.
La dernière incertitude que nous connaissons
est très ouverte et c'est un reniement.
Et si vous ne m'envoyez pas le téléphone ?
Puis-je récupérer mon argent ?
La blockchain nous permet d'écrire du code,
des contrats
entre des individus,
et garantir que ces contrats seront respectés
sans être imposés par un intermédiaire.
Si nous prenons l'exemple du téléphone, on peut penser à un dépôt fiduciaire.
Vous financez ce téléphone
mais vous n'avez pas à débloquer les fonds
avant d'avoir vérifié que les conditions sont respectées,
que vous receviez le téléphone.
Cela doit être l'une des façons les plus excitantes
pour la blockchain de diminuer les incertitudes
car cela signifie en partie
que nous pouvons supprimer les institutions et leur application.
Cela signifie que beaucoup de l'activité économique
peut être garantie et automatisée,
que les interventions humaines soient repoussées jusqu'aux franges,
les endroits où l'information passe du monde réel à la blockchain.
Je pense que ce qui terrasserait Douglass North
quant à l'usage de cette technologie
est le fait que ce qui la fait fonctionner,
ce qui maintient la blockchain sécurisée et vérifiée,
est notre méfiance mutuelle.
Plutôt que nos incertitudes
nous ralentissent
et nécessitent des institutions
comme les banques, gouvernements et entreprises,
nous pouvons exploiter toute cette incertitude collective
et l'utiliser pour collaborer et échanger plus, plus vite et plus ouvertement.
Je ne veux pas que vous ayez l'impression
que la blockchain est la solution à tout,
même si les médias ont dit
qu'elle mettrait un terme à la pauvreté mondiale,
résoudrait le problème de contrefaçon de médicaments
et pourrait sauver la forêt tropicale.
La vérité est que cette technologie en est à ses premiers pas
et qu'il va falloir que nous voyons la réalisation d'expériences,
et probablement leur échec,
avant de réellement comprendre tous les cas d'utilisation
pour notre économie.
Mais beaucoup de personnes y travaillent,
des institutions financières
aux entreprises technologiques, start-up et universités.
L'une des raisons en est que ce n'est pas qu'une évolution économique.
C'est aussi une innovation en informatique.
La blockchain nous donne la capacité technologique
de créer un registre des échanges humains,
des échanges de monnaie,
de tous genres d'actifs numériques et physiques,
même de nos attributs personnels
d'une façon entièrement nouvelle.
D'une certaine façon,
elle est devenue une institution technologique
qui a beaucoup des avantages
des institutions traditionnelles utilisées en société
mais qui le fait de façon décentralisée.
Elle le fait en convertissant beaucoup de nos incertitudes
en certitudes.
Je pense que nous devons commencer à nous préparer
car nous allons faire face à un monde
où les institutions distribuées, autonomes
ont un rôle assez significatif.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Bruno Giussani : Merci Bettina.
Je crois avoir compris ce qui se prépare,
cela a beaucoup de potentiel
et est complexe.
Quelle est votre estimation pour le taux d'adoption ?
Bettina Warburg : C'est une très bonne question.
Mon labo est concentré
tout d'abord sur les entreprises et les gouvernements
car, en réalité, la chaîne de blocs est une technologie complexe.
Combien ici comprennent le fonctionnement d'internet ?
Mais vous l'utilisez quotidiennement
et je crois que nous faisons face à ce même genre d'idée à la John Sculley
selon laquelle la technologie devrait être soit invisible soit belle
et, actuellement, la chaîne de blocs n'est aucun des deux,
donc les adopteurs précoces devraient être
des gens la comprenant et pouvant bricoler autour
ou pouvant trouver les meilleurs cas d'utilisation :
la vérification de l'identité et des actifs, des contrats informatiques
pouvant être utilisés au niveau d'une entreprise ou d'un gouvernement.
BG : Merci. Merci d'être venue à TED.
BW : Merci.
(Applaudissements)